Good mor- You know I think I'm just
gonna let Calvin do the intro for today.
Good morning Hank.
Calvin, how many parts do you
think we want to do today?
This video comes in 2 parts.
And so it shall be
Part one: You. Hank, as I was watching your hilarious video yesterday and
indeed as I've watched your previous 130 videos, I always feel surprised. I hope
you won't be insulted by this, Hank, but
i'm surprised that you're so smart and
funny. And I think I know the reason I'm surprised. It's not because you just
became smart and funny it's because the last time I knew you really well, you
were 11. And Hank, you can say a lot of nice things about eleven-year-olds but
their wit does not tend to be nuanced.
For instance all the jokes I told when i
was eleven broadly speaking went like
this: set up set up set up set up set up
get you ready for the punchline, are you ready for the punchline? Are you ready
for the punchline? Poop. The punch line
was always poop, Hank. Whereas now that's
only the punchline like thirty percent
of the time. I think today for a lot of
people siblinghood is a relationship
that occurs primarily in childhood and
then when you're adults you still talk
but you mostly talk about your parents
or your other siblings or familial
matters of some kind. And you end up
stuck with the same image of your
siblings that you had when they were
little.
We're busy grown-ups who live across the country from each other and there's not
always time to add "In your pants" to book titles and see who can come up with
funnier ones. By the way Hank, my tripod today is a stack of books and one of
those books is called "Pompeii - tales from interruption" in your pants. I think it's
an increasingly rare pleasure to know
your siblings as adults and I have to
tell you Hank, I am so grateful for this
project primarily because I now know you
as an adult; as a smart, funny, clever
person full of ideas both brilliant:
naming our forum "My Pants", and diabolical: making me wax my chin. But Hank, I think
it's safe to say that as much as we've
enjoyed this project with each other we
never would have finished if people
hadn't watched. First because it was hard
and second because I love not to finish stuff.
Oh and speaking of not finishing stuff, Hank, I went back through the Brotherhood
2.0 archives to find the first time
that either of us ever mentioned a viewer
of Brotherhood 2.0 and it was
actually on like January fourth. The
nerdfighter in question - and remember
back then nerdfighters weren't even
calling themselves nerdfighters - was
Peter who had just had a baby and I was
all like "We're gonna
get Peter a baby warming present!" but then we didn't. Because i love not finishing
things.
Fortunately, when fleet sent me an extra copy of "Mummy, how do I know if I'm a
nerdfighter?" I'm going to send it to
Peter 362 days late baby warming present
and then I will have actually completed the task. Take that brings me to part 2:
Nerdfighters. Hank, before I go I need to make one thing clear:
Nerdfighters are not about you and me. Nerdfighters are about a made of awesome
book made by a woman in Australia going to a made of awesome baby in the United
States. Nerdfighters are about raising
money and awareness for important causes.
Nerdfighters are about building a
supportive community of friends in my
pants.
Nerdfighters are about stupid beautiful projects and making each other laugh and
think with t-shirts and pocket
protectors and rants about the situation
in Pakistan which sucks right now. In the contemporary world where things fall
apart and the center cannot hold, you
have to imagine a community where there is
no center. Hank, at the end of this year I started to think that a lot of life is
about doing things that don't suck with people who don't suck.
That's why I enjoy the Happy Dance
project in The Project for Awesome so
much. All these people who don't suck
came together to do something that
doesn't suck
and as I recall that's the point of the
scavenger hunt. Nerdfighters I'll see you
in my pants and Hank, thanks for all of
this. I'll see you on Monday.
[singing] I know it could end real bad but I wish
it didn't have to end at all yeah I wish
it didn't have to end at allllll.